resistance has proven its value this is
one of the chants we've been hearing
from Palestinians here who have been
protesting in support of the prisoners
exchange deal they say that Israel if it
were up to them they'll keep Palestinian
prisoners in Israeli jails but those
deals are able to release Palestinians
from Israeli prisons I've spoking to one
of the mothers she was holding a picture
of her two
sons this is good news without a deal
our sons will never be out of jails
especially our women we've been seeing
how their conditions are getting worse
and worse so this is kind of a good
gesture a sign that Palestinian
prisoners are going to be out of Israeli
prisons Palestinians are expecting
Israel to continue its bombardment on
Gaza they believe that more killing is
going to happen but this is a short
break they believe it's much needed for
Palestinians they say that they've left
and lost hope that the world will help
them to reach a ceasefire so they can
only have themselves to rely on ibraim
Al jaaz the occupied West Bank